marie tu vas m'exécute
vas-y alors elles et comment elle est
très bien aller non les magnifiques elle
est bien été vécue certainement pour
beaucoup de gens c'est un mec qui croise
son pote dans la rue et ils aident le
mec à 12 points de suture sur le front
comme sa douce musique ici tu arrives et
vadis et ma femme dit quoi ta femme va
nous elle m'a foutu un coup de gigot
d'agneau congelés en pleine gueule dit
pourquoi le fait ça vins de cépage elle
se baissent si c'est pour aller chercher
le gigot dans le congélateur elle ou
l'apport sms elle avait sa petite ruche
push police et comme j'adore
j'arrive derrière elle je retrousse un
petit peu ça juges écartent le le string
je commence à le prendre que çà et là de
quoi le métier sèche de décalage groupe
a qu'est ce que tu fais quoi
d'habitude elle adore ça toi hélas la
trappe
gigan 1 me fous la gueule le gym est
pourquoi le fait savez ce que tu dis que
d'habitude elle adore ça eh ben dis je
sais pas peut-être mais ce qu'on était à
auchan
biden
c'est le petit singe à son papa l'a
alors valu la rime au bar et ils
s'agrippent aux contrats comme ça les
deux garçons vous avez des bananes et le
garçon ait dit non on n'a pas de bananes
métissage ai dit vous avez du banal dit
non je viens de vous dire je vais pas de
banal même 10 1 vous allez bonne à
lignol me redemandent encore une fois si
j'ai du mal
je tire la langue jacou ce sera pour toi
et là de petits sajidi où je vais des
clous mais non j'ai pas de clous
alors vous avez des bananes c'est le 21
50 appartements
le mari le oui j'ai peut-être parler
fort à sa femme pour une fois c'est la
blague qui le veut il dit chérie j'ai le
shampooing pour toi ça va mieux un goût
quoi tu veux comme des fausses et sans
les thèmes du salon
le seul vrai c'est que tu parents sont
là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gagné s'est éprise 1 classe une casse
tous les élèves évidence on de marseille
la cité a dit quel sens qu'ils sont les
supporters de l'om et tout vécu à ses
oies sauf un dans le fond le petit
antoine
la suisse ne s'en étonne elle va voir
dib a eu entrave
tu n'es pas supporter 2 2 l'om dit non
madame
moi je suis supporter brestois
ah bon mais pourquoi diverses que mon
père et les supporters brestois ma mère
allait supporter brestoise et mon frère
et ma soeur sans supporters brestois
alors moi je suis supporter brestois
c'est unicef à antoine tu as aussi son
libre arbitre quand même la tunisie
libre arbitre ici c'est quoi madame
alors que mal voit qu'il comprend pas
lui dit entre elles je devais un exemple
plus simple imagine que ton père soit un
gros connard et ta mère une salle où
étaient frères et soeurs ivoiriens
soient là tu serais quoi est atteint
divine baschera supporteurs de l'om
le médian de chez lui la femme a trouvé
son mari alimenter un peu vite dans la
chambre un peu à l'improviste on va dire
à tous son mari à poil complètement à
poil sur le lit tout transpirant toi
avec la marée situation un peu court
pour ça il dit que si tu arrives tu
chéris et lui il est un peu pris de
panique dit que je crois que je suis en
train de faire une crise cardiaque
ça va me descend quatre à quatre les
escaliers elle tombe se sont petit
garçon de quatre ans qui lui dit ma main
il ya un tas lisette elle est
complètement tenus à l'est dans
l'armoire de la chambre lit quoi elle
remonte cas d'agathe alou la porte de
l'armoire voit sa soeur à poil
réunissent à la salle alors mon mari
c'est une crise cardiaque et que tu joue
à cache cache et
[Applaudissements]
a marseille il est ivre mort cinq heures
du matin il n'a pas trouvé une gonzesse
arrêt en chope une haie la sortie de la
boîte il a coincé sous une porte cochère
que ça te fait il est appuyé qui titube
ont donc obligé d'appuyer diallo fille
dit tu vois ta tête je vais te prendre
et tu vois la bm je vais talonné sur le
capot s'est arrachée et ajuste au string
c'est vrai je mette la pression que j'ai
si vite un soleil et une fenêtre au
dessus qui s'ouvre rien mais gonflé au
cimic tu la prends comme tu veux tu
lâches l'inter
[Applaudissements]